une demande de parole de monsieur charon
excuse moi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
l'histoire du droit de vote est un
chemin précieux de l'histoire de notre
pays et de notre démocratie
il est éclairé par un principe simple un
homme une voix
si dans l'histoire la mise en place de
cet idéal fut longue et parfois
douloureuses nous devrions espérer qu'en
2012 50 ans après l'instauration du
suffrage universel direct lors
d'élection du président de la république
et 67 ans après l'accord du droit de
vote aux femmes et aux militaires nous
soyons pas revenir honoré au mieux ce
fameux principe pourtant si l'élection
présidentielle respectent effectivement
le un homme une voix
les élections locales sont soumises à la
loi de la carte électorale
il ne s'agit évidemment pas ton
contester le principe dans la mesure où
les évolutions de population sont
inévitables et la mobilité une des
caractéristiques principales de la
société contemporaine cependant notre
rôle de législateur est bien de mesurer
ces évolutions et d'y apporter la
réponse la plus respectueuse du grand
principe qui régit la représentativité
de l'élu dans notre démocratie
malheureusement les ajustements de la
carte électorale n'ont pas toujours été
réalisés sans arrière pensée il est
d'ailleurs amusant de noter qu'une forme
de justice immanente a souvent punies la
main qui avait essayé de tendre le cou
aux électeurs un peu de silence mes
chers collègues s'il vous plaît si le
président ne le fait pas c'est à moi de
le faire
c'est aujourd'hui en tant que sénateur
élu de paris que j'interviens sur cet
article qui modifie la clé de
répartition des élus parisiens au regard
des évolutions de population qu'ont
connu les différents arrondissements de
la capitale
depuis 30 ans le tableau fourni en page
67 du rapport est à cet égard tout à
fait clair et présente un certain nombre
de problèmes quant à l'équité des
variations proposées par ce projet de
loi en effet si la population a
globalement légèrement augmenté dans la
capitale
nous constatons de fortes disparités
dans la répartition de cette
augmentation
la logique de la réforme de la
répartition des conseillers de paris
devrait donc visait à rétablir les
équilibres de représentation en ajustant
le nombre de sièges aux évolutions
constatées dès lors comment comprendre
par exemple que 17ème arrondissement se
voit priver d'un représentant alors que
sa population est stable à 0,6 pour cent
faisant passer à 14 mille le nombre
d'habitants par élus alors que dans le
même temps le 4e arrondissement qui a vu
chuter sa population de 10 7% garde ses
trois sièges ce qui équivaut à un ratio
de 9000 habitants par élus plus
généralement comment ne pas soupçonner
une autre logique que celle de l'équité
quand les trois conseillers de paris a
ajouté dans ce projet de loi l'ont été
dans des arrondissements majoritairement
à gauche et que les trois qui ont été
retirés l'ont été dans les
arrondissements majoritairement à droite
7e 16e 17e les 1er 2e et 3e et dans une
moindre mesure le 4e arrondissement
profite d'une sur représentation au
conseil de paris et ce à double titre
leur population prise en totalité a
fortement diminué en trente ans sans que
cela n'affecte pour autant le nombre de
conseillers de paris qui sont déjà et
seront élus après le projet peut-être
est-il temps de réfléchir à la question
du regroupement des quatre
arrondissements centraux au sein d'une
seule et même entité
pour l'heure le projet de loi ne règle
pas mais institut dialyse un
déséquilibre qui existe depuis 30 ans et
qui conduit à ce que la voix d'un
électeur du centre d'un capital vaut
près du double de celle d'un électeur
parisien autres comme il apparaît dans
le tableau la fourchette se situe entre
eux 5871 habitants par élus dans le 1er
arrondissement et 15000 69 pour le
cinquième soit plus de deux fois et
demie cette disparité qui compte plus
que les évolutions démographiques
elle même aurait pu être rééquilibrée à
l'occasion de ce projet de loi bien au
contraire
elle est aujourd'hui accentuée dans les
trois arrondissements concernés par la
suppression d'un siège au conseil de
paris en passant par exemple pour le
7ème arrondissement
de onze à quatorze mille habitants
paraît lui il ne s'agit pas d'une
réforme mais bien d'une manipulation
visant à fausser la représentation les
électeurs des 7e 16e 17e arrondissement
au conseil de paris
la solution la plus équitable me semble
être celle proposée par l'amendement de
notre collègue yves pozzo di borgo dont
je suis co signe que des cosignataires
pardon et qui consiste à définir à deux
le nombre de sièges au conseil de paris
pour les 1er 2e et 4e arrondissements et
a13
ceux du 16e et du 17e mais chaque
collègue
il est de notre devoir de législateurs
de veiller aux meilleures conditions
d'épanouissement de la démocratie et non
de l'aménager indignement pour truquer
ces équilibres je vous remercie
nas et chers collègues